james
yes
[Music]
no
never you
because it is always present
[Music]
this month before flying
our self
[Music]
and to you they
only say well
now
but not
neglected suddenly
s
and where the birds
next season
[Music]
and long
live
everyone indicated
goodbye to motorcycles
[Music]
I play
nation
yes no
once indicator
how people are
and what they don't
[Music]
I don't come to get it
the north station
d
[Music]
yes
no
now  yes let's go
[Music]
and now
huidobro
does not vary
era
braun
historical
[Music]
of leisure
are the muscles
[Music]
about gamesa
ah
[Music]
go back
d
[Music]
as superior
as in the world
yes  no
[Music
] skillful activity we put on
moderation
[Music]
to
to the
goal approach
[Music]
private
and
[Music]
song other
better
good
[Music]
[Applause]
yes
[Music]
but
god
scotland mentions
and at  final
like this
with silver
where the two
in canarias
[Music]
I see
i
cows were
now
[Music]
and then
yes no
[Music]
good
guarenas of music
[Music]
and
[Music  ]
of the same
[Music]
I
the substation
and
as can be expected
[Music]
yes
[Applause]
[Music]
but I
[Music
] coffee
[Applause]
[Music]
welcome
my function
[Music]
step 5